Long Live Palestine Long Live pales a
world away from Gaza demonstrators fill
the streets of the Australian city of
Sydney waving Palestinian flags and
chanting for freedom in
Palestine surrounded by heavy security
they marched 3 kilm from the Sydney town
hall to the harb side to make their
voices
heard will not surrender to the Israeli
occupation one Banner reads against
occupation others compare Palestine to
Ukraine or draw attention to the state
of imprisonment in which over 2 million
Palestinians have been living in Gaza
for the last 16 years the Palestinians
have enjoyed enough and enough is enough
that's it it's amazing I'm actually on
the verge of crying so um I really want
an end to this occupation um just like
South Africa um did experience that end
of um genocide I think I would like to
see that for Palestinian people we are
all
Palestinians Australia has a large
Muslim and Arab Community including a
sizable number of Palestinian refugees
the right of return is still the core
demand of those who were forced from
their homes in Pre Israel Palestine in
1948 but as these protesters gather
outside the Sydney Opera House the
building lights up with the colors of
the Israeli flag a strong reminder that
these protesters do not represent the
official view of the Australian
government Australia unequivocally
condemns the attack on Israel by
Hamas support for Israel has been
unanimous Across the Western World
especially by EU and US
leaders even in Ukraine which says it's
dealing with a foreign occupation
Israeli flags have been displayed in the
streets of K and
solidarity India also has EXP pressed
support for Israel while Iran Venezuela
and South Africa were among the
strongest supporters of the Palestinian
side in the Arab world a few limited
rallies and gestures of popular
solidarity took place in Jordan Yemen
and
Kuwait Arab governments on the other
hand seem to prefer either silence or an
nuanced call on all sides to avoid
escalation at a un security council
meeting in New York Russia China and
Japan stress the need for Israeli
occupation of Palestinian lands to be
addressed if a lasting peace in the
region is to be achieved Muhammad
Al make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer